i'm also looking at the rise of hobbies
and uh and amateur
stonework and how a lot of our
gem gemologic techniques were actually
invented by amateurs
which means just lovers as opposed to
professionals the amateur is the lover
and
hobbies i don't know if you know but the
word hobby comes from a hobbled horse
and so you would hobble a horse me to
keep it from running that's hobbling it
with a with a stick or a
string
and then kids would ride a hobbled horse
for play a horse on a stick
and riding a hobbled horse becomes
riding a hobby horse and then that
becomes a hobby
and so hobbies become this so-called job
you can't lose in the great depression
in the 1930s and then they explode
[Music]
and so when i was a kid people would
collect coins or stamps or fossils or
this or that so i'm interested in that
collecting
passion
so it's interesting um the development
of hobbies because it feels like the
future of human civilization would be
very hobby driven
like um
some of the like i i often now
because of this particular little thing
i'll do with the podcast i get to
interact with photographers and
videographers
and i'm disappointed to find
how many professionals are not very good
and how many hobbyists are very good
yeah
so
it's well if they're amateurs they're
the lovers i mean they're loving it
that's what that means from a moor
you're an amateur if you're a lover of
the thing and it you're not in it for
the money yeah you know because you're
obsessed but the sort of
as the uh gdp as the
um as our freedom grows to sort of
financially to be able to have a hobby
it feels like there'll be more lovers
more amateurs in the world and not just
for the artistic pursuits but like
science
uh technology development
building you know uh building all kinds
of technologies almost like as a hobby
yeah
you have much more freedom to figure out
what is the thing you love doing
and actually over time
that just you won't even notice but i'll
start making money
and yeah that's really fascinating and
yeah it does
kind of uh
i mean
when did that originate just the
collection the
why it goes through different stages
people have always
gathered the odd thing to make something
else
but
you also get this tradition of what's
called curiosity cabinets
especially in the renaissance
which replaced the kind of treasure
chambers of the ancient sultans or kings
or whatever and you get these curiosity
cabinets they were often linked with
magical practices alchemical practices
people would gather
besoirs or they would gather they would
have an alligator hanging from the
ceiling or they would have a rare you
know shrunken head or whatever and
that's part of the rise of natural
history the idea you taxonomize the
world you classify the world you look
for the rare object the rarity
and rarity still is a kind of virtue
like the recent
news about trying to figure out ball
lightning when i was growing up ball
lightning was the big question does it
exist does it not exist and now there's
new evidence of how it actually might
wait what really there's new evidence
yes yeah there's i grew up with that
my dad when i was young told me i asked
him like how do i win a nobel prize
he said uh invent a time machine or
figure out how ball lightning works
and so i got really excited i was like
damn it i'm going to figure out how this
ball lightning works it's very
interesting from a history of science
point of view because it's so rare
that in a way it doesn't exist you can't
replicate it you can't make it does it
really exist it's a little bit like
libyan glass another thing i collect is
libyan glass which is a tectite
which
falls
as a result of a meteorite a meteorite
hits the earth blasts earth up into
space it falls back down
as a glass that's called a tectite and
there's a rare form of it called libyan
glass
which fell probably around 20 million
years ago
and now works out of the sahara every
now and then it was the most valuable
stone of antiquity
the centerpiece of tuttan kamon's
breastplate is made of this beautiful
yellow
gemstone libyan glass
so
rarity is something that
the hobbyists have always liked
you